hallo leute vor ein paar monaten haben
wir bei petrol unsere easy german
supporters kampagne gestartet
wir haben euch dazu aufgerufen unser
projekt freiwillig zu unterstützen damit
wir in zukunft mehr zeit haben um easy
german videos für euch zu produzieren
über 80 leute sind seither zu
unterstützern also zur kathrins von
unserem projekt geworden ihr allein
macht es möglich dass wir nun zum
beispiel mit eurer hilfe die miete für
dieses kleine studio hier in dem wir
videos für euch produzieren zahlen
können und dafür möchten wir uns heute
bedanken
wir haben euch ein video versprochen in
dem wir euch ein bisschen
hintergrundwissen und fun facts rundum
easy german bieten
und hier sind für euch neue easy damen
in side effects in episode 1 begrüßt
simon das publikum mit helau ti und
trank wein trank wir hier in westminster
aber wir sind ihren tank tatsächlich
sind hier und rang zwei vietnamesische
studentinnen von denen wir gehört haben
dass sie deutsch lernen und dieses video
war ursprünglich erst mal nur ein
privates video das für die beiden war
wir haben das damals auf youtube
hochgeladen aber wir wussten noch gar
nicht 2006 was youtube überhaupt ist er
später ist dieses video dann sehr
populär und sehr berühmt geworden
fun fact nummer zwei in episode nummer
zwei fragen simon die menschen auf der
straße wo es eigentlich zur beringstraße
geht könnt ihr mir den weg zur
beringstraße sagen wer ins treffen
keine ahnung schade aber in münster gibt
es gar keine behringstraße genau
genommen ist die beringstraße die
meerenge dies zwischen russland und
alaska gibt ihr wisst das bestimmt oder
hat davon schon mal gehört aber haben es
die leute in unserem video gemerkt
german insider effect 3 wo ist episode 5
wie ihr wisst gibt es mittlerweile über
100 episoden von the german nur eine
fehlt und das ist episode nummer fünf
immer wieder fragen leute von euch wo
ist episode nummer 5 und tatsächlich ist
gab mal eine episode nummer 5 und sie
war auch bei youtube damals jedoch zu
den anfängen
von youtube war es noch gar nicht so
einfach zwischen produzent und youtube
und den zuschauern zu kommunizieren
tatsächlich hat sich damals jemand über
das video beschwert und hat gesagt er
möchte nicht in dem video drin sein oder
irgendwas stimmt mit dem wieder nicht
und youtube hat dieses video einfach
gelöscht ohne dass wir einspruch erheben
konnten
oder dass wir etwas dagegen tun konnten
leider haben wir das video auch nicht
mehr gespeichert und jetzt ist es daher
leider weg das heißt es wird leider
niemals eine nummer fünf episode von
easy german geben
fun fact 4 in episode nummer sechs seht
ihr meinen ersten auftritt bei easy
german hallo und herzlich willkommen zu
unserem deutsch sprachkurs nummer 6 wir
haben uns super gefreut letzte mal über
die viel mit vielen positiven kommentare
und die motivieren uns natürlich super
jetzt weiter zu machen
wir haben vor einem supermarkt gefilmt
und haben leute gefragt was sie gerade
eingekauft haben
habt ihr eigentlich bemerkt dass am ende
der supermarkt episode ein anderer
supermarkt zu sehen ist als am anfang
das liegt daran dass wir ursprünglich
zwei visionen drehen wollen
vor dem ein supermarkt und vor dem
anderen hallo was habt ihr denn heute
ein kauf ich mir dabei woran ist du ein
kauf jeder weg ist vor dem zweiten
supermarkt wurden wir allerdings weg
gescheucht wir konnten nur ein paar
interviews machen
dann kam der supermarkt manager super
böse denn er wollte nicht dass wir auf
dem supermarkt gelände filmen und er hat
uns einfach weggeschaut
das heißt leider gibt es bis heute nur
eine supermarkt- und einkaufen episode
fun fact nummer fünf in episode nummer 7
seht ihr den ersten gastauftritt eines
zuschauers bei easyjet hallo und
herzlich willkommen zu unserem easy
german kurs nummer 7 wir sind heute in
köln wir haben einen ganz besonderen
gast hier
denn wie jedes mal haben wir ganz viele
tolle antworten bekommen aus allen
in der welt von menschen die deutsch
lernen und so ein zuschauer ist auch dem
aus brasilien
jim war damals tatsächlich die erste er
kommt aus brasilien und wir haben ihnen
in köln getroffen als allerersten
zuschauer
und er hat auch als erster eine
gastmoderation übernommen
heute machen wir das öfters und jim war
damals ganz neu in deutschland das war
vor sechs jahren mittlerweile lebt er
seit sechs jahren in münster
und wir sind immer noch gute freunde
easy german inside effekt nummer 6 die
frage der fragen warum haben wir
ungefähr sechs jahre gebraucht um die
ersten 20 episoden zu produzieren und
haben dann aber 100 episoden in zwei
jahren gemacht die antwort ist ganz
einfach
als wir angefangen haben mit diesem
projekt da hatten wir nicht das ziel
dass wir ein großes projekt namens easy
german aufbauen wir hatten auch nicht
das ziel youtuber oder so etwas zu
werden sondern wir haben einfach nur
einen kleinen test gemacht ein kleines
projekt gemacht und das resultat auf
youtube hochgeladen er später haben wir
gesehen dass viele leute hilfsprojekt
schauen und dann haben wir immer mal
wieder ein paar neue episoden gemacht
und erst vor zwei jahren sind wir
eigentlich auf die idee gekommen dieses
richtig professionell zu machen und
regelmäßig zu produzieren
easy german insider effekt nummer sieben
in episode nummer 18
seht ihr zum ersten mal manuel vor der
kamera hallo liebe fans von easy german
wir sind heute in der münsteraner
innenstadt und werden die leute zu ihren
berufen befragen es gibt ja viele berufe
die man so nehmen kann die man lernen
kann und ausüben kann und wir wollen mal
schauen was die leute so machen
los geht's wieso hat er damals
angefangen mitzumachen
erstmal ging es eigentlich um ein ja ein
bisschen privates interesse von manuel
ehrte damals nämlich einen podcast zum
thema berufe und karrieren das ganze
hieß wie wird man und er hat immer
wieder verschiedene berufe und
berufswege vorgestellt deswegen hat er
lust auch eine easy german episode zum
thema berufe zu machen
den podcast produziert er leider heute
nicht mehr aber man kann sich die alten
episoden immer noch anhören
und vielleicht habt ihr lust mal rein zu
gucken das ganze ist nämlich auf seiner
website noch online
und hier findet ihr den link inside
effekt nummer acht
wer sind eigentlich die menschen die man
bei easy german vor der kamera sieht
nicht seht ihr schon relativ häufig bei
easy german aber die meisten episoden
sind immer noch von gastmoderatoren
moderiert und wie wird mein
gastmoderator damals als wie sie damit
angefangen haben war es eigentlich eine
übung die wir mit schülern im rahmen von
unseren projekten gemacht haben wir
haben damals eine medien ag in einer
schule gemacht und hatten einen verein
und erst mal war das einfach nur eine
witzige übung um menschen auf der straße
etwas zu fragen und zu lernen wie man
film schneidet und untertitel baut
deswegen seht ihr gerade in den ersten
episoden immer wieder viele schüler und
ganz verschiedene projektgruppen die mit
uns medien workshops gemacht haben
hallo leiter kameramann chantal und ich
komme aus thüringen und wir sind hier in
münster am schiller gymnasium und machen
einen medienworkshop mit globex perin
und mir ging es auf die straße neue
leute kennenlernen es regnet zwar aber
wir haben mit treffen trotzdem ein paar
leistet später sind dann auch immer
wieder ganz viele freunde dazu gekommen
ungefähr ein drittel der leute die über
easy german seed sind einfach menschen
aus unserem privaten umfeld hatte klein
herz das häufig ja und die dritte gruppe
die ihr bei easyjet vor der kamera seht
das seid einfach ihr dann unsere
zuschauer also ihr ihr schreibt uns
immer wieder mit vielen von euch treffen
uns auch und viele von euch schreiben
uns auch dass sie selber mal eine
episode moderieren möchten
hallo leute wir sind heute wieder
endlich mal zurück auf der straße in
berlin und zwar sind wir mit oma aus
ägypten und mit anders aus indonesien
das haben schon ganz viele von euch
gemacht und es macht uns unglaublich
spaß und wenn ihr lust habt auch mal
dabei zu sein und schreibt uns doch
gerne eine e mail an info at - languages
dot org easy german inside effekt nummer
warum heißt easy german eigentlich easy
german den german ist doch gar nicht
easy
zumindest schreiben dass einige von euch
immer wieder fragte uns warum heißt das
easy german und jetzt kommt der knaller
ganz ehrlich wir wissen es auch nicht
wie ihr wisst haben wir deutsch damals
angefangen also easy german dieses
produkt haben wir angefangen als eine
art test kam es bei youtube hochgeladen
ohne dass wir wussten dass dieses
projekt jemals bekannt wird dass wir
damit über 100000 subscriber und
zuschauer erreichen
und na ja mit der zeit haben wir auch
angefangen diesen namen zu mögen und es
war natürlich auch einfach diesen namen
beizubehalten und die nicht mehr zu
ändern
heute mögen wir den namen und natürlich
wissen wir dass deutsch nicht super
einfach ist
trotzdem hoffen wir dass wir mit unserem
semmeln videos euch ein bisschen dazu
ermutigen können dass es ein bisschen
einfacher wird
in diesem sinne verabschieden wir uns
jetzt bei euch und danken euch sehr für
eure treue und unterstützung um ganz
ehrlich zu sein wir sind sehr sehr
dankbar für all eure unterstützung
als support eure kommentare und eure e
mails sind tatsächlich der grund warum
wir uns irgendwann dann dazu entschieden
haben
easy german regelmäßig und mittlerweile
sogar täglich zu produzieren und euer
finanzielle support auf katrin ist dabei
mittlerweile ein wichtiges standbein für
uns geworden denn im moment können wir
von den werbeeinnahmen die unsere videos
auf youtube auch erzielen
leider noch nicht leben jeder cent und
jeder euro den ihr in dieses projekt
investiert ist daher besonders wertvoll
für uns und wir investieren ihnen gleich
doppelt zurück mit unserer zeit und
unserer liebe für dieses projekt vielen
dank euch allen